- I freaking love "Ted Lasso".
(audience cheers)
Imma nerd.
I know everyone says this.
I'm not original, but it's
just such a great show.
It's so innovative and different
from all the other shows.
And it's just a great, it's a good time.
And I think, especially for
everybody that's just been,
felt trapped or maybe
having a (beep) year.
I don't know if you can
say (beep) year on here,
but I just did.
- It depends on the year.
If the year was (beep) enough,
you can say (beep) year.
- You can label it. But no, and
it's just such a great show.
I don't know one person
that doesn't like this show.
How does that feel?
To be part of such an amazing
show that everyone loves?
(audience cheers)
That's gotta feel cool.
- I mean, it's surprising and awesome.
- Is it surprising? Y'all
didn't know, you didn't think?
- No, we thought, you know,
it was probably gonna be pretty good.
There sure were a lot of
talented people involved,
but you know, we've all been fans of shows
that then got canceled for
reasons we don't understand.
- Yeah.
- So we never could've
anticipated, you know,
that I'd get to come here, first of all.
- Yas! I would've never
anticipated. I was very excited.
Well, who inspired your
character, Coach Beard?
Did you have an inspiration?
- Several.
- You lucky man. You had
several people inspire you.
- I used to work as a
stagehand at my student union,
Illinois State University in
beautiful, normal Illinois.
The Bone Student Center, a.k.a The Boner.
(audience laughs)
And the guys I worked with
there, who were my bosses,
we're just all these,
like, wonderfully, laconic,
very Midwestern, but way
smarter than they let on, guys.
Who were just very dry, very droll
and they would just drop in a
nugget when it had to be said.
Like I remember one guy, he lost his radio
and just sitting there,
just all squat in the back.
He lost his radio, someone
had stolen it or whatever,
and he goes, "Oh no. My nomenclature."
Like, nomenclature?
We're in normal Illinois.
Who's saying nomenclature?
- Droppin' that knowledge.
- Yeah. So yeah, those guys.
- I love that. Well, you
guys shoot in London.
I love London, especially
at Christmas time.
What's the biggest cultural
difference for you?
- Well, one's a physical manifestation
that people make fun of, but it's true,
is every time I cross
a street, I might die.
That never goes away.
I've now spent a year of the
last two years of my life
in London and everyday,
several times a day,
I could die the most
awkward, embarrassing death
that I'll be known for forever.
And I never, ever get used to that.
I have to at every intersection, be like--
(Brendan gasps)
- Do they just not pay attention?
- Well, they're just
comin' from the wrong way.
(audience laughs)
- Well, it's the right
way where they're at.
- But we know.
(audience laughs)
- But is it?
So wait, you had a son, well you didn't.
That've been amazing.
But, congratulations.
He's one and half now, so that's amazing.
(audience applauds)
Are you still getting
used to being a daddy?
Oh my gosh. Oh my g--look at the glasses.
You got a little Beatle on your hands.
It's, like, amazing.
- He's amazing.
He was born out there because
the world being what it was,
we had no other choice
but to have him out there.
- Wait, so he was born in London?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's cool.
- While we were filming this last season.
- He's already cooler than you.
- Oh yeah.
(audience laughs)
And they don't even
give him a passport yet.
He was born there, but he
can walk around, you know,
grade school and be like,
"I was born in London. It's
cool. NBD. Merry-go-round time."
- "I'm basically amazing.
I'm Colin Firth."
That's amazing.
So you became friends with
your co-star, Jason Sudeikis.
Right? Did y'all, like,
hit it off in Amsterdam?
Is this what I heard?
It's a place to become
friends with people I think.
- Isn't it? We knew each other
in the Chicago improv scene, basically.
And then I moved to Amsterdam
to do comedy out there.
And then he eventually followed.
And that's when we became,
like, real solid friends.
And that's where I
started telling him, like,
"Hey man, soccer doesn't
suck. Check it out."
And now it's our job.
(Kelly laughs)
- And it's the best job ever.